on the mound for the halos with a record
of three and four in a 3.52 era
left-hander patrick sandoval now matt
olson one of the best sluggers this year
one pitch and that's a chopper hit on
the right side it's a fair ball it's
fielded by fletcher and underhands a
toss to goslin they get olson so a quick
clean inning for patrick sandoval here
chris bassett on the mound tonight love
his stuff love his competitive nature
great mound presence tied for the
american league leading wins and winning
percentage
ranked second in innings pitch scott's
gonna deal tonight i'm confident so one
out for phil gosselin
dropped into shallow right loriano
i love the backhand slide gave himself
time popped up and listened in that
exchange was clean love the
communication between him and marty
that's also a rhythm out there that's
going to be important and something to
be able to watch for sandoval now has
the bases loaded the nine hitter tony
kemp is coming up here's the two strike
pitch he got him swinging struck him out
and that's how the inning will end it
started with a strikeout it ends with
one and they leave them all on base
chapman now he's popped out
one two
that's gorgeous that's the change up
just like you drew it up
83 off the black by about two baseballs
and you have a hitter that crushes off
speed pitches this is how special this
pitch is for sandoval
when you have that type of numbers a 667
slugging percentage versus an all-speed
pitch yet you missed that change up by
that much it tells you how good that
pitch is for patrick sandoval he missed
that chapman he missed that by a lot so
three singles here in the fourth lowry
murphy now andrus here's kemp oh two
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
six so far sandoval has done a
tremendous job against them
running that fastball inside canada last
night was on base three times over two
tonight bases loaded
and he went with a changeup and missed
badly so the a's get a run as lowry
trots in to score on the bases loaded
walk
yeah overthrew the change up and type
this is the third time he's gone 3-2 and
went change-up
and he's frustrated because he sees what
he wants to do he believes in it but
when you overthrow the baseball you
don't allow to get your hand on top of
it to get out in front dangerous hitter
their newcomer starling marty will bat
with the bases loaded
martay rolls it mayfield cuts it off and
just gets the out at second base that
was tight kenneth had a good jump
fletcher was there and sandoval limits
the damage to just the one run
one nothing oakland up in a
basket with a glove near the body fires
and he got him
up and in
and that's three strikeouts for chris
bassett so he gets the dangerous upton
great fastball this was a sinker that
was riding in tied up just enough and
there was nothing he could do with that
pitch but foul it off but when he's able
to stick that fastball in there's not
too many hitters in baseball that can
square that baseball here's mars he hit
one on the left side handled by the
third baseman chapman his first time up
he's a left-hand hitter
pass it out of the stretch comes to the
plate and a swing and a messy sailed one
up and away with a four seamer marsh and
the angels are done in the fourth inning
they get a hit they leave two and we're
on to the fifth inning and it's still
one nothing oakland eaton now struck out
in the third then mayfield
that's a liner and that's it
and that's extra basis for eaton into
the corner
he's got a gun and he picks it out of
the corner he gets it in quickly eaton's
got a double and the angels have a
runner in scoring position
good job for getting down and getting
that pitch after
two pitches off speed in a row out of
the strike zone patient got one in his
zone
blinds it down the court that's a cutter
stays through the baseball and lines it
down in the corner
eaton often races
the halos have eaten at second we're in
the bottom of the fifth at the belt and
now the o2 delivery curveball stopped to
the right side to his left campus got to
flip the first in simon great job by
basically works out of it keeps the
angels off the board and after five it's
one nothing athletic sandoval gonna push
through 100 pitches here and try to
avoid the top of the order
mayfield
yes
he's had trouble with balls adam but
anything he leaves his feet for it's
spectacular great range
gets up quickly and makes a perfect play
at first base thanks sandoval loving
that defense
of jack mayfield at third tonight a heck
of a play this ball again right down
that third base line to his right lays
out for it
gets up quickly and then just shows that
good strong throwing arm across the
diamond
114 pitches
in seattle in seven innings that the
career high infield shifts now
can be tricky with the ball up the
middle
especially if you've got a smart runner
he can go from first to third if you're
not careful
he went he went again he stayed inside
every single pitch today every pitch
against ken and that's it joe baden
on his way out 115 that's a new career
high
20 swings and misses tonight he left it
out there tonight a one-nothing game
next fish number 90 for the ace
right-hander they lead from first and
second left-handed hitter here's the
one-two delivery it's on the way swung
out of miss and a high fastball and
bassett works out of it the halo strand
two they fail to score to steal one
nothing athletics so two outs and here's
jack mayfield
bassett has the tip off his glove kemp
bear hands fires to first and they got
him so chris bassett with a five pitch
inning he needed it and that'll bring up
chat when his pop down struck out and
bounced into a force play put in one in
the seat chapter
well
nice to get an insurance run that's for
sure
it's that one to left center field it's
d and i'm good
that baby's gone and the a's have taken
a two nothing lead
matt chapman delivers a huge home run
for the athletics
as they get a little bit of a cushion in
the eighth inning his 14th homer and his
second on this road trip two nothing
athletics up to now at third but the
angels are down to their last out
oh two broken bat right side olson
shovels and the game is over oakland has
shut out the angels again
and this frustration this futility
just continues for the angels they can't
seem to score a run at all
against oakland